hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the jeans and the beans
high-quality reference genomes provide
tools for coffee breeding improvement
presented by Susan Strickler PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by ductile genomics ductile
genomics is transforming genomics by
making long-range genomic information
readily accessible to all the company
enables researchers and clinicians to
solve complex problems involving de novo
assembly structural variation cancer
research and more by providing a
comprehensive view of the genome their
proprietary proximity ligation and
informatics approaches simplified
genomic discovery by integrating the
highest quality long-range genomic
information with next-gen sequencing
output for more information please visit
Delta G no mix com I'm Judy O'Rourke of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce today's speakers dr. Schwinns
Howe who will be providing an
introduction to dovetail technology when
a former dovetail genomics customer who
led became law genome informatics
recently joined the team as
bioinformatics production
manager Schwinn received his PhD in
computational biology from the
University of Sydney prior to Doug hill
Schwinn served as the NGS bioinformatics
officer at the Australian genome
research facility did his postdoctoral
fellowship and was lead genomics and
bioinformatics research scientist at
cows in Saudi Arabia and most recently
the senior manager at a stark in
Singapore
dr. Strickler is a director of the BTI
computational biology Center at the boys
Thompson Institute dr. Strickler is the
lead bioinformatician of the Arabica
coffee genome consortium and her
research aims to produce genomic
resources to be used in comparative
genomics gene family analysis and other
studies to better understand the
evolutionary history of coffea arabica
and to develop tools for the improvement
of coffee through breeding please join
me in welcoming dr. ho and dr. Strickler
I will now turn the presentation over to
them thank you Judy well welcome to this
webinar and we're very happy for you to
be to be able to join us over the
Internet
so just a very very brief introduction
to myself I was a previous customer of
the skill when I was creating the genome
for quinoa at the problem time we were
looking for an effective solution to
build a genome up to a chromosome skill
and the still had the technology that
caliphates what we needed so in this
slide in the middle or to show some
steps that we actually presented at pack
2 or 1 fix a little while ago which is
also found in a nature paper how if
you're interested as you can see there's
a improvement of n50 all the way from
2.4 mega base all the way up to a 3.8
3.8 4 mega base so we were very happy
about this and which is why I'm
continuing my work at Tokyo to work more
on genome assemblies but this whole talk
is not about keno and I'm interested to
tell you about the underlying science
that makes this all possible so just to
go forward this is who we are
this bright looking a bunch of people so
this is what we do so in a nutshell we
do genome assemblies all the way from
lobby preparation we can do sequencing
of it for you and once we have the data
we can do a 14 de novo assembly all the
way to get an assembly and with the data
that we get from Chicago and an IC we
can do a scaffolding for you all the way
up to chromosomal level assemblies we
understand that no two genomes are the
same and they all come with their own
challenges therefore is our goal that we
want to make it a more fully integrated
for example two chromosome I mean very
bespoke service so that you guys get
what you want out of this project as for
example when you go into a restaurant
you probably want to look at the menu so
that is just a very simple list of
things that we offer see we actually do
high molecular weight DNA extraction and
this is actually very important because
it generates intermediate scale
information all about 100 KB so we
talked a little bit more about this
later when we discuss the different data
set but just bear in mind that having a
good input is really important for the
success of your assembly and the next
thing we do is that we do library prep
we do a normal library perhaps like a
Lumina PacBio
and we also do our proprietary library
preparation in this case Chicago and the
high C later in the talk I will talk I
will discuss about the trade-off between
these two different library preps and
also the complementary aspects of the of
the data characteristics when you
actually done the library prep we can
sequence it for you we can sequence
shotgun sequencing we can do paper bio
sequencing or if you prefer to do it
yourself we're more than happy for you
to do the sequencing once you have the
the data come in come back and once we
have it if you're doing if you have a
shotgun data we'll run it through our
or shotgun assembly code miraculous or
if you have a long read PacBio and we'll
put it to a falcon to get a starting
point well scaffolding and the next step
is the scaffolding where we have the
high-rise or Chicago dataset this is our
proprietary proximity ligation scaffold
which we call high-rise we used to
stitch many pieces of small scaffolds
into the way up to chromosomal level
assembly and finally before we give it
to you if you have any shotgun data that
you generated long before that you want
to use any other ways or yet peg by or
low coverage peg bio data we can
actually use it to get filled assembly
and just to the aim to increase our
contact continuity okay with all these
things a lot of handful so let's go into
the science of the molecular pile of
this approximately ligation approach why
is it important because on we want to
share with you how this can help with
the genome scaffolding in this slide is
a little bit busy I have a cartoon
illustrating the different step and in
this approach all the way from left to
the right so the left you have DNA and
all the way to the right you have data
coming out from sequencing I just want
to point out right now this this applies
to Chicago and high C and the Chicago
and high C applies to the middle part so
the middle part of this cartoon is
pretty much the same for both kind of
libraries and what's different between
Chicago and IC is the starting point all
the way to the left for Chicago you
start from pure DNA and that's how you
start where's for high C you really
start from host tissue or cell and the
difference is in front and also that
back which is a different aspect of data
to get out okay so without further ado
let's go into the science part of it so
in this use Chicago as a it's a starting
point
should we follow along with me so on the
left hand side you see the little black
take the black black line and therefore
you can see that there is a little one
and two okay
just gonna throw it out here for you can
you see this one and two okay
all right so imagine that this is DNA a
single strand of DNA there's about 100
KB and points of point number one and
two on on this DNA it's about 100 KB
apart and it represents one long strand
so what we do is that first we do for
Chicago we actually reconstitute the
chromatin we add enzymes histones and
DNA and the enzymes actually real
sociate the histones to DNA and DNA
wraps around the histone one good thing
about this is that it happens in a very
uniform fashion and rather evenly across
the whole fragment as you can see in the
second part here okay once this happen
it's actually allows us to go to the
next step so the histone is very
important because they access handles
for the next step which you'll
understand very shortly we actually
cross-linked the solution next as you
can see in this rate pass between the
little blue circle so this cross-linking
causes form covalent links between the
histones and as a result of this a
previously very long DNA
I'm from the first step it is bounded
together somehow now in a bit of more of
a globular form what this means
essentially if you can see from this
illustration here okay
it's that point point 1 & 2 which is
previously very distant away in the DNA
it's now brought together into close
proximity so this is a this is the the
key part of this proximity ligation
approach next we actually use a
restriction enzyme to cut out the this
DNA aggregate and as a result that
causes sticky overhangs which is very
normal and one what you get out of this
is that from a single long DNA fragment
now you have numerous fragments of DNA's
and the good thing of the crossing is
that because the crossing was done
before he actually retains the proximity
ligation information there before we do
the next step once we have this we
actually feel the overhang at the same
time and we we want to be able to
capture this kind of information so we
add a marker so in this case is a
modified nucleotide of about in the
church as you can see this is this part
is a little green little green area okay
and this is important because it allows
us and rich for those very important
fragments to you see next
next we actually perform ligation to
fragments with the party now actually
fuse together and what you might imagine
is that because the fragments are whole
health in close proximity throughout the
cross link it's more likely to like it
fragments they are close together there
are some random fragments that in
solution what that also means is that
the chimeric molecule is form both a
very predictable statistical
distribution that we will be able to use
later for scaffolding as you can see
from this step here 1 & 2 is actually
fused together so it's perfect for us to
retain that
finally we actually Franklin the DNA
further remove the cross links and
remove the proteins and what you get in
this case are ovm we remove the buttons
at the end remove the the proteins and
what you get at the end are fragments
with biotin in the middle this is very
important because now we can enrich for
those fragments with those parties which
represents the important ligation that
took place because of proximity ligation
with this we can put into the sequencer
and with that where she sequence both
sides and you can see that we actually
sequence very close to location 1 and 2
in your whole genome so and then because
we put it to a high rise and high rise
uses your scaffold your assembly and put
that with the difference between Chicago
and high C so I've mentioned this whole
process I've just talked about Chicago
so where does high C come in for those
of you who like to bring your genome to
the next level where you want
chromosomal level assemblies with a high
C we do not reconstitute the chromatin
so actually we fix the chromatin in
vitro within the nuclei of the cell and
what this does is it retains very long
range information much much longer than
extracting DNA and we can obtain it in
cases where you actually can get full
chromosome information from this which
I'll explain a little bit later in the
next slide where we look at data
characteristics so before we move
forward I just want to kind of elicit
kind of discussed a little bit about
what you might want to consider is the
data recipe right when you do a genome
assembly noemi's is good that was ideal
that your data representing the genome
from different skills all the way from
short intermediate only without founded
long range and just to make a make it
clear what we mean by short intermediate
long a short scale in in our perspective
will be something less than 100 Kb so
those were copper libraries with your
shotgun data you make their libraries
even a long week PacBio
which is very very long but in this case
in the whole perspective the whole
genome is Sorella C sharp is less
another KB and then you want to have a
proportion of your data coming from
scales so this will be in order of a
hundred of KB's and technologies out
there you have is that's available to
you in your arsenal of scientific tools
to Chrome apps which we also be
previously dated for project in Kino up
and 10x technology and also Chicago is
so easy now to do that
and finally this long range massive long
range Fukumoto information right now
there's only the high C methodology
including our own dovetail proximity
ligation approach so you can see that
with all this recipe you put together it
kind of helps you build a better genome
at the end result okay make step we just
want to look at the information what
count data in yet so right here I have
two plots on the Left we have they're
the same data set this print tesam
plotted on two different x-axis and the
reason why we're looking at this is that
I want to explain to you the correct
three sticks of the different kind of
data on the Left plot you have the
x-axis all the way up to five hundred
kilobases
and on the right you have all the way to
a hundred mega bases so every single dot
shows this separation and the y-axis
show the proportion of repairs we didn't
the library that falls at any given
separation and what you can see is I'm
in the field Chicago in green you can
see that it's a decay as it goes getting
bigger and bigger and maybe all the way
up to 100 Kb and you can see you see
there you can see since you see them
beta about 250 KB but majority of it is
within the hundreds of Kaylee's okay and
if you put that in the perspective or
shotgun sequencing may pay and even long
region backed by a long ways you can see
that where I'll take where this
intermediate scale be able to complement
all this short short range information
one thing to take out from from this
from this picture on the Left we can see
that
the dk4 in green for info cigar go
Chicago actually cannot Plateau so even
cannot like decays all the way after
2050 KB you know I'll say about hundred
KB but on the dovetail high C we
continue to see the kind of a flat all
the way to the right that which you can
get information beyond final KB which is
why we're actually showing you the plot
on the right so in this case the scale
is much bigger up to 100 mega pieces so
you can see that the the characteristics
of high C actually goes all the way even
at 100 mega bases so so this is this is
really really healthy encouraging
because it gives you a different mixture
instead a recipe different data set so
that we can help you do the data this
releases some results of what we did so
this is a project that we did grave i
always use Brentford ciao
so close it's a bob white bird and so
what we did for this projection we did a
shotgun sequencing we did a de novo
assembly of the shotgun with it some
chicago's scaffolding and all the way up
to a high c scaffolding and we have
three different plots here just to
explain what this plot means so every
single on x-axis are the individual
scaffolds assaulted from the biggest to
the smallest and then on the y-axis is
the reverse of that so you can end the
density of that the color density within
each boxes represents the information of
how things are coming together right so
you can see that the first thing that
you see in my from from de novo
chicago's all the way to the right i see
the boxes get bigger this is this is
very expected because when you do it in
over assembly the scaffolds are very
very small which is why it doesn't cover
a lot of
x-axis and when we move on to Chicago we
can actually the x-axis boxes actually
get bigger so in this case a lot bigger
and in this case when we actually move
all the way to the high C it's even much
bigger in this case we can see here they
I mean this is my pointer okay
this is actually going up to foo
chromosome scaffoldings and one thing
that I like to point out is that if you
can see this little lines here of a
large here this little lines here these
are actually what we see as
characteristics of the Chicago data that
there are some scaffolds that that seems
to have some information of linking
between another scaffolds and what we
could not resolve at the Chicago level
we were able to resolve that at a high
sea level because you mean even longer
range information to solve them so it's
a very neat project because if we put a
laughs all the way to right we're in for
a very tiny
entropy assembly all the way to a full
chromosome assembly and what is nice is
that it's also created with it just
eight weeks from sample receipt to data
what this means in terms of genome
utility is that you carry data faster
you can start working on it to solve
whatever problems that you guys wanted
to in the first place
this is a lot of birds we have because
we were actually very blessed that we
were able to also work on on different
genome assemblies in this case a reptile
lizard and the facial in the middle and
also the plan which is latches so
similarly I was seen for the boat white
bird progress how we start off with a
500 KB and 50 after Chicago he went up
to 15 mega bases and after high she went
up to 90 mega bases and for fish it was
24
kilobases for a starting assembly it's a
little more fragmented in this case the
data wasn't as easy but well but the
Chicago actually saved that because
while we could bridge this 24k beef or
fish after Chicago we got 12 MB [ __ ]
Reez and we add hi-c it was able to
rescue that employee one megabases
same for plants from five hundred
kilobases up to 6.5 after we add make a
basis after the and chicago and all the
way up to close to 300 mega bases this
is at some point this is basically no
even exciting because this we are
reaching full chromosomal level so just
to illustrate what is the utility of
this technology that we have here as far
as polyploid we were able to work on
this project where we had we did a de
novo sequencing assembly with the
Chicago and hi-c for this tetraploid
plant this Cantus you can see under on
the left hand plot is beautiful we
achieve a chromosomal level assembly but
more importantly for the science part of
it we promote we learn from the P I
cancers it's separated from sorghum
about six million years ago and there
seems to be a duplication event all the
bleeders or duplication event about 4.5
million years ago so we do a comparison
we have top plot on the right between
the cancers on the y axis and sorghum on
the x axis you can see that Wow
this is this could be really seen
because from every pair of McKenna's
genome you could see a corresponding
mapping to sorghum
so this is very very true out the whole
genome so this is a great validation of
designs and and just to make sure that
there was this as a polyploid and to
make sure that we are chetori right
obvious they look at looking at scalpels
actually mapping back to their linkage
map we see a jet created from a genetic
map you can see that there's a very nice
separations of homologous scaffolds this
little dot here over here can you see it
can put here little dots here you can
see that these two scaffolds Caroline
it's linked to linkage group language
which shows the utility of having a good
starting point genome with that I like
to close off this last two slides sister
I'm sure you guys the complementary
characteristics of having Chicago versus
hi-c and what I have here in these four
boxes on the they are the same data set
sorry this is Chicago data and hi-c data
mapping to the same scaffold just to
illustrate our point and on the on the
left column we have the Chicago data on
the right column we've got hi-c data and
on the x-axis is the midpoint where the
parent maps on to the scaffold n we have
and on the y axis is how far apart the
reads are mapping to the scalpel okay so
if a map is a if a pair of each map very
close together then you will appear a
little more on the bottom of the y axis
it is mapping further apart it should be
map you should see the dot a little bit
more that pipe on the top part of the y
axis and the first thing that you see
that you can see from this pattern is
that you've got a higher density of
purple dots at the bottom of the y axis
that means that yes it's what we see
from decay a lot of the the data are
mapping closer together and as you
increase the distance via lesson a few
entries dots going above up on the y
axis so this is very expected but what
we did was that we wanted to know
whether what happened in there so
actually conversion so we artificially
went into this scaffold and inverted
50 kilo base contact within the scaffold
and now what you can see is that I'm not
sure whether you can see with your eye
Wow let's just help you there so this is
Casey this pattern we can see this
displacements of grid pair it's actually
raised three means that they are they
are mapping slightly higher than it's
normally seen the human eye is normally
quite great picking out this but imagine
looking at it throughout the whole
genome I heard I would want to be doing
that
I'm sure this elevated and that's where
the algorithm comes in and what you can
see in Chicago is that there that it can
identify this kind of missed placement
and and because this is a particular
basis 50 kilo base pair inversion you'll
see they're in a high sea level and I'll
just advance to the next slide so you
can see where the the breakpoint is you
don't see the same kind of information
at a high sea level which means it's
when you go in the high sea you have to
assume that your data is actually
inclusive is actually very good which
points which kind of like to close my
toe in the sense that we want to the
intermediate scale information that you
get from Chicago data is especially
useful if you have a very fragmented
starting assembly because you will be
real go in and find out regions like
this and try to correct them
unfortunately we won't be able to
correct this information if you jump
straight into the high sea with a very
fragmented something and this is just my
last thing that I like the highlight and
thank you everyone for listening to us
and I just like to let Suzy talk about a
project thank you
okay thanks a lot for that so I'll talk
a bit today about some work that we've
been doing with our coffee genome and
I'm speaking on behalf of a large
consortium of people which I'll talk
more about at the end so I'm sure I
don't need to make the case that coffee
is important and so many people can't
get through their day without a jolt of
caffeine but there are some other
reasons Coffee earth is important as
well so it's one of the world's most
valuable agricultural commodities it's
an especially true in developing
countries where coffee is the top
exported good and many comedy
commodities are traded at a higher level
but they aren't as valuable it's also
thought to be the largest source of
antioxidants in the Western diet with
many possible health benefits so it can
reduce the risk of things such as some
types of cancer type 2 diabetes and
dementia there are many economies that
are driven by the production of coffee
onions you're probably aware it's also
threatened by climate change so you can
see in the map here some of the regions
that are the top producers of coffee two
different types of coffee there's or
busca and Arabica which I'll talk more
about and they're all more in the
tropical regions which are known to be
affected will be affected by climate
change so for example a study finds that
Ethiopia which is the world's fifth
largest coffee producer could lose up to
60% of its suitable farming land by the
end of the century there are three main
species that are used for drinking
coffee but the actual coffee genus has
over 120 species so they're native to
tropical Africa and Asia and they've all
evolved rather recently on the
evolutionary timescale so you can see
here the three different species that
are used mainly for for drinking coffee
so coffee Arabica would be the main one
so this would be your drip coffee or
espresso your lattes this accounts for
about 75% of coffee production then the
second highest production would be from
coffee kenitra
which you can see here in the middle and
it accounts for about 20% of production
and it's not
not taste quite as nice and it's more
frequently used for things like instant
coffee and there's also a very small
amount of coffee liberica that is used
for for coffee production to drink so
that accounts for less than 2%
production the coffee bean which are
probably well familiar with is actually
the seed of coffee so you can see here
in the top left of the slide the coffee
cherry so these are the coffee fruits so
they start green and they turn red when
they're ripe and then they're harvested
and they're dried and the outer husks
are in is to result in the coffee beans
and then these beans are roasted to get
the coffee that you you would drink with
your morning breakfast there are a
number of things that can go wrong here
so you can see in this in this poster
that there they can be affected by
wetness whenever they're drying they can
be over dried they can be crushed so
whenever you're you're thinking about
coffee production you don't only think
about the actual genetics of the coffee
and growing the coffee but then there's
this whole post harvest step that comes
in that can affect the cost coffee
quality so I'll be focusing on three
main species today that we've done a
number of genomic studies on so these
are coffees annuities if you can see on
the top left coffee coniferous in the
top right and coffee Arabica so Arabica
is derived from a cross that happened
billions of years ago so relatively
recently on the evolutionary time scale
between two diploid ancestors so you
know DS would be the female parent and
kanafeh is the male parent so rabbika is
actually something that's known as a
tetraploid so it has both of the
parental genomes and I should say that
Kenneth freh was actually previously
sequenced in another study so we've
we've added a bit of a bit of data to
that one as well which I'll tell you
more about an upcoming slides you can
see here the distribution of coniferous
and you Genuity so there
a slight overlap in north and
northeastern africa and rabbika found in
ethiopia at slightly higher elevations
so for people that don't work on plants
polyploidy is is kind of an interesting
maybe unexpected thing to come across
there are a lot of plants that are
actually polyploid so you can see here
some of some of the ones you may be
familiar with
so potatoes are what are what's known as
an auto polyploid so this means it's
genome is derived from a duplication of
a single tax on and then the other
species that you see here are known as
allo polyploid so their genomes have
derived from two or more diverged taxa
so for example strawberry is actually a
octopod so it has eight copies of its
chromosomes tobacco as a tetraploid
cotton as a tetraploid and wheat is
extra complicated and it's actually a
hexaploid and most plants are also
ancient polyploid so we call these paleo
polyploids which had a duplication event
a very very long time ago and they have
remnants of these throughout their
genome which can add complication to
assembly an analysis since a lot of
these regions are there and more than
one coffee
so the coffee genome is not is not super
big here we're looking at Arabica so it
has the biggest gene a lot of the three
that I've mentioned the tetraploid so
it's a bit bigger than a rabid Optus
which is the model plant this is the
first plant that was sequenced but it's
it's smaller than the human genome and
much smaller than the wheat genome which
as I mentioned is quite large so why
should we sequence the coffee genome so
our goals with this project are to make
a template basically that can be used
for student studying genetic variation
so diversity within coffee different
coffee accessions diversity is really
important in breeding because by looking
at diversity we can find accessions that
may have resistance gene
Coffee has a number of pests and disease
problems that need to be need to be
dealt with through breeding there also
quality issues so if we can get to the
basis the genetic basis of quality then
this allows us to do more efficient
breeding so those are some of the more
applied reasons for for a coffee genome
and also we're interested in the
evolution of coffee so as I said it's
derived from these two progenitor
species and there are a lot of really
interesting things that happen whenever
there's a polyploid ization event so by
having the two progenitors as well as
Arabica this allows us to do some really
cool stuff could look at on gene loss
and rearranging it and other things of
interest so with any sequencing project
there's a number of things to consider
and a number of different data types
that that need to be incorporated to get
a high-quality genome so these are some
of the different things that we we
considered for our project and starting
with plant selection so that's that's
the first thing that needed to be
considered because plant genomes can be
quite complicated so we need to decide
which plant should we sequence so as I
said coniferous in previously sequence
so the the individual that we sequence
was actually the same one that was
published previously and we've added
more more data to that to try to improve
the assembly a bit
so Khafre is a diploid as I said
previously but the one that we sequence
is a mono haploid so this means that
there should be no hetero zygosity
whenever we assemble the genome and do
downstream analyses and this particular
individual huge annuities is a diploid
as well but the one that we used is
heterozygous so this one is not a mono
haploid and there there should be hetero
zygosity whenever we look at the
resulting assembly and both of these
have a haploid number of 11 chromosomes
so rabbika on the other hand they said
as a tetraploid so it normally would
have two copies or four copies of every
chromosome but the one that we used is a
special a special accession and it's a
die haploid so this one has 22
chromosomes instead of the normal
tetraploid number so you can see here
what sort of what a cartoon of what a
die haploid is so with the tetraploid
you could have variation occurring
between the homologous chromosomes and
you could also have variation occurring
between the homeotic as chromosomes with
the die haploid any variation we see is
only going to be coming from the two
homologous chromosomes so the two
parental species essentially so this is
really nice for assembly purposes
because this is essentially like
assembling a very heterozygous
individual instead of having variation
coming from between the chromosomes and
across the sub genomes so the next thing
that was really important that allowed
us to do this was the availability of
long sequencing reads so we had
initially attempted to assemble rather
coat with Illumina reads and we were
never able to get very good assemblies
by using an Illumina and part of the
problem was the repeats in the genome
were breaking context and so our
assemblies were never very good so we
set out after our Illumina attempts to
to do some assemblies with tach bio-data
so you can see here the types of data
that we had for for initial assemblies
of coniferous annuities and Arabica
Arabica was the first one that we
sequenced so we have a little bit of
older technology mixed in with that one
Arabica we had about 56 X coverage of
the genome ingenuity this is about 58
and coniferous about 77 we used a pretty
standard assembly pipeline so each of
the genomes as you saw had greater than
50x genome coverage from PacBio sequence
then we took that sequence and we did
the standard self correction and
assembly so depending on the genome
different assemblers produced different
results so I'll get to that more later
for conferral we had some scaffolding
and mate pair reads and also some back
sequence so we were able to we were able
to do scaffolding with that and then
some gaps going with P
jelly and in the pack bio reads Arabica
a new Genoa tease since these were
essentially heterozygous we use Salkin
unzip to assemble those and then we
polished all of the assemblies with
Illumina reads that we had from from
other sequencing projects from the same
individuals and then we took these and
we sent them off to dovetail for hi-c
and then we took those and we filled
them in with PB jelly and the original
PacBio reach so this is this is what our
contig look like so this is before any
further scaffolding or hi-c was done so
we have the publish can differ on the
first column so you can see with that
look that one looked like so that one is
not sequence with tat bio and then we
have two different coniferous M bleeds
that we tried one was with M half and
the salera assembler and another was
with Falcon in this case we found that
the M happens where assembler produced a
little bit better assembly it was a bit
longer and n 50 was a tiny bit higher so
that was the one that we used for for a
downstream analysis then we also had two
different you know ATI's assemblies both
were essentially ran with Falcon but one
used some DNAnexus specific parameters
which performed a little bit better so
that was the assembly that we that we
went move forward with there and then we
had three different Arabica assemblies
that were done with two different
versions of Falcon so one was an older
version one was a newer and then we and
then we ran falcon unzip on the assembly
from 2016 so this is this is the
assembly that we use for all further
analyses here overall you can see on the
coniferous assembly seems to be
performing the best which is probably
expected to each this one is a mono
haploid and should have essentially no
variability usually no ideas is slightly
worse because likely because of the
hetero zygosity issue and then Arabica
of course is the most complicated one
since this is our
I have wood so this slide should look
pretty familiar to you and I think
you've had a pretty good introduction to
that so I don't need to go into it in
too much detail but we we took our our
coffee leaves that we had from our
collaborators in France and they were
sent off to the dovetail for
cross-linking and then the libraries
were created for the for the for the
sequencing and then dovetail did their
their magic and got back to us with some
really improved results so you see here
so these are the results from from the
hi-c scaffolding and so basically what
what happened here
we sent coniferous and arabica we
unfortunately didn't have any more
usually samples to send to do hi-c so
that one stayed the same that's why it
looks considerably worse than the other
two but for coniferous we the hi-c
improves the scaffold and 50 from 972 KB
to 50 mega beat basis which was a 51
fold increase and approximately 87% of
the assembly is contained in 11
chromosomes so that's really good
because we should you know the goal is
to get to 2 chromosome level and where
we're nearly there
so the arabica assembly this genome
again is a little bit more complicated
it wasn't quite as good but still very
impressive improvement so an N 50 of 760
KB to 45.8 for mega bases so this is a
60 fold increase over what we had sent
them the original context it has been
scented up to and so about 74 percent of
this assembly is contained in 22
chromosomes so this was very helpful for
us since we want to do comparative
genomics and this will really allow us
to do that
so then we wanted to look a bit more in
these some assemblies we see how they
were performing so we used lusco as a
metric so these are genes that should be
present in single copy in most plant
species and so we looked through our
assemblies and then also through a
rather
and tomato to have a comparison to some
genomes that we know we're good to see
how many of these we were able to find
so we have the publish connect for there
as well and you can see that our Arkana
for assembly is is a little bit better
and then it has a couple more single
copy genes and a few less genes missing
compared to the published usually
performed so lately worse likely due to
the hetero zygosity and Arabica of
course is is the dye haploid so here
what we're detecting is the homologous
gene copies here so that's why you see
so many that are duplicated so that's
that's expected we also compared the
kennefa a genome to the unites genome
and we're expecting these to be pretty
similar because previous work has been
done that it's found that there they're
quite quite similar so you can see the
11 chromosomes from kennefa on x-axis
and the 11 chromosomes from ug noise on
the y axis and these are just dot plots
that show the comparison on a per
chromosome basis and there's pretty good
collinearity between the two genomes is
expected so one other thing that we did
and this is we're actually still in the
process of doing we have optical maps
and genetic maps and a lot of short read
sequencing for arabica and the two
parental genomes so we've taken the
arabica genome and we're assigning the
homeo logs so that we can tell which
parental genome that they're most
similar to and then also we're doing a
bit of checking of the assembly
assistants we have the optical maps were
able to see if there have been any miss
assemblies or as things are looking
pretty good overall and and so far from
the work we've done things things are
looking looking pretty agreeable so now
that we have these genomes of course the
the more interesting thing is knowing
about the genes and finding them in the
genome so further work can be done there
so we have I so seek data from PacBio
which has been really great for
annotations in sick
you basically the whole transcript
length and we've used that as well as
est s and RNA seek to to run the maker
pipeline so we train the ab initio
predictors augustus and snap and then
we've used all this expression data to
predict the gene models in the genome
and then these we're predicting a
functional prediction based on blast two
different databases and also interpro
scan to see the go terms to these we
also set up a web apollo instance which
has been really helpful for the manual
curation of genes so this can also help
you improve your training set to for
Augustus and other predictors so this is
just showing an example of a gene model
that we've set up in that system that
then people that are part of the
consortium that's been able to go in and
find their favorite genes so things may
be involved in caffeine biosynthesis and
other pathways to make sure that they've
been correctly annotated and if not then
they can actually manually fix them so
this will help improve our gene models
in the long term so far this is what our
annotations are looking like so this is
pretty comparable to to the published
coniferous included tomato and Arab
adopters as well and so this is still a
little bit of a work in progress to sort
of fine tune these this is probably one
of the more difficult things in genome
assembly and producing a good genome as
a resource is really getting the gene
models as good as you can and as you can
see arabica i have roughly twice the
number of genes as connector and usually
so this is another indication that that
it looks like we're able to detect both
homologues of the two from the two
parental genomes in the assembly this is
so just looking at busco again this time
we're looking at the actual annotation
so before we were looking for these
these genes in the genome now we're
looking at the annotations to see if
they're in the protein models that we've
did so if you look at coniferous so our
version is there's the 1.4 it's it's
performing pretty well based on the blue
skull metric so the sanitation is pretty
pretty um pretty set but usually Dee's
well you saw the genome is still missing
some gene so we're just not really going
to be able to detect some of these
because they didn't assemble very well
for some reason or another and again
you're seeing an increase in duplicated
genes and arabica which would be
expected so the next step because a
genome by itself isn't really so so
interesting is to do some more work to
look at some of the genetic basis of
interesting natural variation that I was
explaining previously so trying to find
genes that might be involved in pathogen
resistance insect resistance things that
be useful in breeding and also we're
interested in evolution of coffee so
we'll be using our genomes to study that
and also on in our lab we have the
tomato database called Seoul genomics so
one of the big things we do there is
develop toolkits for breeders to use so
you can go there and so this example
it's tomato of course but you can go
there and you can find things like
markers for breeding various phenotypes
genes that are involved in interesting
characteristics you can identify qtls
using tools there so the goal is to get
information from coffee into into a
similar resource so that so that
breeders and the public can access this
and then the goal is to help improve
coffee so I'd like to acknowledge the
Arabica coffee genome consortium which
is a pretty large group of people from
nine countries eighteen institutions and
53 researchers and also big thanks to to
dovetail for allowing me to speak today
dr. ho and dr. Strickler for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. ho and dr. Strickler please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is our first question is how
long does it typically take to go from
tissue to delivered assembly and this
question is for dr. ho sure thanks Judy
so in general depends on what you need
to be done but in general we takes about
12 weeks from the day that we receive
your sample after the day that we
deliver the report and the Finance MP
for you of course you need to do de novo
assembly which we also provide a service
use this stickers a bit longer in
general about 12 weeks and before we
move to the next question I want to
advise with a series of poll questions
will appear on your screen during the
Q&A you may select your answers and
close the poll questions by clicking on
the X in the right corner ok this next
question is for dr. Strickler what
percentage of the genome was masked for
the repeats and how did you avoid
masking something that you should not
sure so I think in the end about 60% of
the genomes were masked whenever you
look at the 3 on different genomes that
we worked on so they're pretty pretty
comparable since they're closely related
and the way we did the repeat masking
was we first looked for de novo repeat
so we used repeat Scout and repeat
modeler and then we we filtered those
repeats for known protein domains
because if you don't do that what ends
up happening is sometimes you can mask
out things that are members of gene
families so we filtered our repeats in
removed things that were were known
domains and then we used that set for a
repeat masking so that that did a pretty
good job of not masking things that it
shouldn't do I mean nothing is ever 100%
perfect but
it was as close as he could get okay
this next one's for dr. ho we are
looking into getting an assembly about
working on what approach to use do you
provide consultation and options that
address our concerns about price and
quality
I'm sure absolutely so um I to be honest
we we will not start the project until
we have a good idea of what the
expectation on on the genome because we
understand that no two genomes are the
same they come with their own complexity
there are all different sizes as Suzy
has a sherry bus about coffee so we're
definitely here and we'll be here to
help you and try to decide what's the
best strategy forward for your GM size
for your vehicle and complexity and also
a price range that would match what you
need to do downstream so absolutely
we're happy this next one is for you too
could we get two whole chromosomes with
the de novo and I see I would love to
say yes but I guess we have to be
realistic first of all I'm chromosomal
level assemblies depend very highly on
the input assembly right of course them
from what we have observed from our high
rises high sea rice if your input
assembly is close to in megabases
that's where the hi-c library where I
should fly and if you're able to stitch
things into closer chromosome or
chromosomal level and which is why I
like to illustrate discuss a little bit
more about why we actually have Chicago
as well because it will import assembly
is not that big or the entry fee is not
that great you need some kind of
intermediate scale library data to
actually bring it up to where high C can
actually bring it down to two possible
so yeah so that's the answer
dr. Strickler this next one is for you
UC Davis announced earlier this year
that they had sequenced the Arabica gene
how does that work relate to the work of
the AC GC and what were the main
differences in their approach and your
consortiums sure so yeah it's completely
different groups and they're actually a
number of groups throughout the world
that are currently active in sequencing
a particular accession of Arabica or
another I to my knowledge were the only
group that's doing a dye haploid so that
should give us a bit of strength because
it should be a bit easier to assemble
but it'll be interesting to see how they
how they all come together and to have a
number of different accessions so we can
look and compare do some comparative
genomics with what comes out of these
different consortiums dr. ho's this one
is for you and I'm not sure which slide
it apply to is this technique applicable
to plants only well absolutely we can
well plant is a to be honest it's one of
the most challenging things is as Susie
has mentioned it all these colleges
regions we have had success with our
mammals as well as you can see from the
slide fish and reptiles and they are
generally a lot easier to assemble and
put into a chromosomal level assemblies
so absolutely yes this next one is for
you for a tetraploid genome 4c let me
just read this over once before I ask it
to you for technology for a tetraploid
genome for which you do not have die
haploids
are you open to try it sure of course we
have some clients that have approached
us with exactly the same same problem we
understand that it's always not easy to
get the haploid so we are most happy to
have a discussion and the most important
thing is to find a viable solution for
for your power plant which is why with
you okay and dr. Houk in assembly is
generated by any means B scaffolded with
Chicago and or high seed and if so what
qualities do you look for in
put Assembly's I'm sure yes possibly so
as far as that we have gone through yes
this any assemblies be PacBio whether
you've done a short gun we can scaffold
it with hyeseon and pilot in Chicago and
this next one is for you can you go
straight from a de novo assembly to hi-c
and one would you Chicago sure of course
so the difference between Chicago and
hi-c is the is the characteristics of
the data so Chicago is more intermediate
scale so if you're n 50 is in kilobases
we would strongly recommend you go to a
Chicago that will bring it hopefully
bringing up to two mega base level and
15 and once you reach that we should be
able to go up to to use hi-c where we
can which longer longer sand scaffold so
it depends on the m50 size of our next
question is this technology applicable
and induced polyploid species yeah we
for my experience it seems to work
pretty well I'm most happy to connect
with you and see how we can look good
and while we're waiting for additional
questions to come in I would like to
once again to thank dr. ho and Strickler
for their presentations do you have any
final comments no for my side thank you
very much for you guys okay that's it
closer question for you I'm sorry dr.
Strickler before you before you answer
can I throw another question at you sure
have you tried Pat bio and bio nano
assembly as an input for a high C
assembler
is that a question first one oh I think
that when I think that one's for you is
that for
yes dr. ho or shall we save that for
after the presentation maybe a sure no
problem I know yeah I can answer that
so Byron a no assembly so the data
coming from binary is it's also
considered kind of intermediate range
data up to 100k B's yes we can
definitely go ahead with hi-c hi-c data
on top of pioneer no thank you and dr.
Strickler we will look forward to your
closing comments yes thanks a lot for
having me and give me the opportunity to
speak here well thank you thank you both
once again I would also like to thank
our sponsor dovetail genomics for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's web
counts will be available on-demand
viewing for on-demand viewing through
March 20th 2018 you'll receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye